hi everyone welcome back the biden
administration
is unveiling the u.s citizenship act of
2021
which would include a number of measures
including a pathway to citizenship for
undocumented immigrants and a pause on
deportations
i spoke with attorney eric palacios
earlier today to get more details
so eric tell us about what changes we
can expect to this immigration
policy well there's a new uh plan that
has been proposed
by president biden which will allow
uh every undocumented person who has
been in the united states
uh since uh 2020 so
just prior to january 1st 2021
if you came in uh now you can apply uh
to stay in the us
and fix your status okay what what about
undocumented immigrants who have broken
the law
and that's uh some of the concern that
we see
uh is the fear that some of these people
might
be criminals or might not have the best
intentions
however with most amnesties and this one
as well we expect that there will be
strict requirements to have
uh follow the law stayed out of trouble
and also uh pay taxes and be current on
those obligations uh prior to any uh
amnesty benefits
uh being provided so this immigration
plan it is not
a done deal yet it's not yet been put in
place
it's not it's just a proposed uh plan by
the administration but it also has to go
through
congress for approval if this happens
then it'll become a law
okay and of course there are more ins
and outs uh when it comes to this but
what other changes can we expect to see
there always are and we'll see what
takes place we'll have more details
in the next few days or weeks
but there's also uh some changes to uh
those that are already
here uh protected by uh their daca
status
this was for uh young immigrants that
came in and uh uh have studied graduated
or continue to study
uh and are current on the taxes and also
maintain themselves out of trouble
they have a temporary status or permit
that makes them legal in this country
now these folks can qualify to buy a
home
with an fha loan which allows them to
become first-time home buyers with
with as little as three percent down so
that's also a great opportunity
uh for uh these folks to now become
homeowners
and plant more roots in the country okay
eric and i'm sure more information will
come out
within the next few days but we really
appreciate you coming on and kind of
going into a little bit more detail for
us very good thank you for having me
and for more information give eric
palacios and associates a call at
visit their 702-444-7777 at
ericpalacioslaw.com